[Music]
most people want to adopt
a cute little dog or a playful kitten
but some want more to love this is why
these animal lovers decided to make a
huge addition to their family
by adopting terrifyingly cute monsters
wait until you see what kris jenner
accidentally adopted you'll quickly
understand
why it is not part of the kardashians tv
show anymore
if you are new to our channel click that
red subscribe button
and give this video a big thumbs up
today you'll get the chance to meet
10 people who accidentally adopted
monsters
esther the wonder pig miniature pigs are
more and more popular as pets
just like a little pink dog with a curly
tail they like to run around
everywhere cuddle with their friends and
wear funny costumes
however don't think these babies will
stay tiny forever
they all grow up to be beautiful adult
pigs micro pigs can be the size of a
small adult labrador retriever
so imagine how big other pigs can be
esther the wonder pig is a great example
of that
the bigger the better you can never get
enough of cuteness with esther
this pink lady was misrepresented as a
micro pig
and sold to steve and derek the little
girl who weighed 4 pounds
grew up to be 500 pounds in less than
two years
they loved her so much they couldn't
leave her so they decided to adjust
their lifestyle to this new family
member
keeping her was the best choice they
ever made and many people agree with
that
esther now has a huge fan club and you
can find out more about her story in her
book
her owners want to share a message to
encourage people to change their
consumption habits
and lead a cruelty-free lifestyle forget
waking up to eat bacon
we want to start our day next to the
beautiful esther the lion queen
actress tippy hadron didn't want to be a
cat lady
so she became a lion queen instead and
she plays with neil
just like she would with any other
feline they sleep together
bathe in the sun or just lay around the
house this big cat is not even scared of
water as they like to play in the pool
together
who thought lions could be so sweet a
trainer taught the family how to act
around the wild animal they were advised
not to send him off
scratch its nose or turn their backs to
the lion but following these
instructions
neil quickly became the family's best
friend and everyone talked about him
however
years after hadrian deeply regrets
allowing lion to roam freely around in
her family home
neil could have turned out to be a
monster she confessed that it was stupid
to let this wild beast
live with the one she loved the lion
could have attacked them at any time
even though neil was nice no one was
able to control him
and a playful game could have easily
ended up in an accident
fortunately nothing bad happened to
tippy she found another way to be close
to wild animals by running a lion
sanctuary
if you ever want to adopt a wild animal
that's your choice but we don't suggest
you walk your lion on the leash
just in case he doesn't love strangers
like he loves you
the smelly monster if you ever thought
that your dog smelled bad
you are not ready for a skunk and you
are not ready to visit deborah chapani
either
she keeps 50 skunks in her home this
woman from ohio runs the only rescue
center for domestic skunks in america
she said she loves these smelly
creatures for the same reason people
love dogs
they are lovable devoted animals and
debra is really devoted to them too
she wakes up every morning at 4 30 am to
make sure they are all fed in time and
clean them
the same routine starts all over again
when she comes back from work she even
sets up her own event the skunk fest
it includes a beauty pageant for skunks
and an award for the best dress just
look at these two
being crowned king and queen deborah
thinks this festival
is a great occasion to help the public
see the skunks in a different light
they've had a bad reputation
because of their smell but she wants
everyone to see that they are much more
than that
deborah might not see skunks as smelly
little monsters but that's what is so
amazing
she sees the beauty behind something we
think is terrifying and we should learn
a lot from that too
the wild dog what can go wrong with an
adorable puppy
once you take home this new member of a
family your life is filled with fun and
unconditional love we couldn't resist
the urge to pet this good little boy
either
however after he was adopted the animal
named neo behaved strangely
he wanted constant non-stop attention
and was always escaping to play with
other dogs
no matter how high the fence was he
found a way out the neighbors were
concerned and this is when someone
noticed that neo had something special
he was not a dog but a wolf dog
it is a mix of the two species this
wasn't good news because wolves are not
meant to be confined
in a human's home and need to be with
other canines when the owners found out
about it
they agreed to place neo in a canine
sanctuary in california the wolf dog now
has the chance to live a happier life
howling at the moon with other wolf
friends this is what love truly is
doing everything so your best friend can
be happy even if that means that they
will have to leave you
the longest cat in the world kelsey gill
always wanted a big cat
after seeing this animal featured in the
harry potter movies she knew she wanted
that type of feline
however what she didn't expect was that
she would get the biggest cat of them
all kelsey adopted ludo at 13 weeks old
and quickly noticed that he was much
longer than the other cats and she was
right to think so
ludo earned a place in the guinness
world record 2017 edition
as the world's longest domestic cat
living he now measures an impressive
1 18th meter or 3 feet and 10 inches
that's
longer than the height of the average
three-year-old child unfortunately
due to his big size pluto is less agile
and much more clumsy than other felines
he is so big that kelsey has to put him
in a dog carrier when they travel
but one advantage is that ludo can't
hide so his owners are
always able to find him easily ludo is a
lazy
big cat he loves lazing around being
stroked and cuddling with his friends
who can blame him we would love to live
the life of a lazy cat sometimes
too the giant pitbull pit bulls are
already really impressive they are
strong
muscular and almost intimidating imagine
what it would be like to meet a pit bull
who's bigger than average like hulk
unfortunately some people only judge
these dogs by their appearance
they have a bad reputation accused of
being violent and aggressive
many cities and jurisdictions all over
the world banned pit bulls or restricted
the keeping of the dogs by breed
typically targeting them
this idea is nothing but a prejudice as
the owner is responsible for the
behavior of the dog this is what marlon
grenon
the owner of hulk wants to prove he
breeds the dog to be unnaturally huge
and sells the puppies to loving families
his goal is to show people
that we shouldn't be protected from pit
bull but that these enormous dogs can
protect
us brendan claims that his dogs can be
trained to any level of protection
including for high level security or
family and personal protection how can
you look at this face and be upset once
you train these dogs to use their
strength in a good way
they will always be there to help you
but dog lovers beware
hulk might attack you with a lot of
cuddles and kisses
the three tigers this family wasn't
satisfied with an ordinary pet
so they bought a tiger then they weren't
satisfied with the tiger so they bought
two more
everything's bigger in texas and it is
true for bill rathburn's cat too he and
his wife raised
three 600 pound tigers since they were
born but what is fun about this story is
the reason why they have these animals
bill explained that his wife just went
out and bought one without consulting
him not only this surprise was costly
but it was also
really dangerous fortunately these big
cats can become
lovable animals when you take good care
of them bill and his wife have nothing
to worry about
not even the law in texas there are no
regulations when it comes to exotic
animals
because they are considered private pets
it means nothing is stopping you from
buying any animal you want
that's probably one of the reasons why
there are now more than 2 000 tigers
living in texas
this means texas police department also
has to deal with tigers on the run
let's hope that we don't meet one on the
street do you think it's okay for
someone to surprise their family with a
new pet we want to know what you think
so leave us a comment
the ferret on steroids this man wasn't
looking for anything unusual
so he bought two adorable toy poodles
what could go wrong with this
look at this little face that makes you
feel like everything will always be okay
however the creatures this man received
seemed to be a little special
he should have noticed that something
was wrong when the dogs were sold for 75
each instead of a thousand dollars but
it was not until a visit to the vet that
his owner
found out he didn't adopt toy poodles
but ferrets
wait these animals don't look the same
at all how can anyone make this mistake
it turns out the ferrets were filled
with steroids and so fluffy you could
barely see what they looked like
even if the man was disappointed this is
not a reason to not turn these little
monsters
into his best friends ferrets can be
adorable pets too
these little creatures love to exercise
and explore the world
you can even train them and make them
wear sweaters just like you would do
with a toy poodle even if the owner was
probably really surprised he's not
missing anything with his new ferrets
the pet turtle turtles can be great pets
for animal lovers who don't have a lot
of energy
to spend and want a best friend for the
next 20 years they come in different
size
are strong swimmers and always act like
nothing is stressful but it seems like
some people wanted a dog instead
and decided to go on an adventure with
their turtle have you ever seen someone
walking their turtle on a leash
there's a first time for everything and
you'll want a pet turtle too once you
see this picture but how do you use a
leash with a turtle
most people just put a collar around
their turtle shell but this one is so
big
there is no way a collar can go around
it this is why someone invented
something to solve the world's most
unusual problem the turtle leash now you
can safely walk your turtle with suction
cups stuck to its shell this man must be
really patient because it probably takes
hours for it to make it to the corner of
the street no matter what
they both look happy together and that's
what counts look at the man smiling
and this turtle confidently coming out
of its shell these two
are meant to be together the new
kardashian sister
kim chloe and courtney rented a monkey
called susie for a week to play a prank
on their mother chris
she was asking them to settle down and
have kids so the sisters planned a
little revenge
chris had to take care of a monstrous
child too she treated susie
just like a human baby holding her in
her arms making her wear pink clothes
feeding her with a spoon and playing
with her around the house
it was so funny to see the monkey
randomly had a bad temper sometimes
unfortunately it wasn't the best time to
play this kind of joke
days before she posted the pictures a
chimp attacked his owner
and the police had to take care of the
situation this is why kim was called
irresponsible and
insensitive when she found out about it
the reality tv star felt really sorry
for what happened
she explained that the pictures were
taken six months before and that she was
praying for everyone involved in the
monkey attack
she didn't mean to insult or offend
anyone you are forgiving kim but next
time
try not to monkey around when it comes
to wild animals you'll see
there is beauty everywhere in the animal
kingdom if you give these amazing
creatures a chance
which unusual animal would you like to
adopt tell us in the comments down below
don't forget to like this video and
subscribe to the things
if you want to watch more videos like 10
common animals that look
out of this world thanks for watching